there's a certain look that's taken over
everything
a certain color palette kind of font and
design
today this visual style sells us meal
kits and underwear
and monthly toothbrush subscriptions and
just about everything else
but it's also showing up here in
seemingly harmless trendy instagram
posts about child trafficking
on instagram there are over 800 000
posts like this
from social media influencers and
regular users with the hashtag
save the children we've seen things like
this before
slideshows about social justice and
current events dominated instagram this
summer
but something else is happening here on
facebook membership in pages and groups
branded as anti-child trafficking
grew three thousand percent between july
and the end of september
by the end of august in-person rallies
started taking place in cities
across the world ending child
trafficking is
hardly controversial but behind that
surge in growth is the baseless
conspiracy theory known
as q anon now an ideology once confined
to the more obscure parts of the
internet
is finding its way mainstream one
instagram post
at a time
on october 28 2017 the first of a series
of posts from an anonymous user appeared
on the 4chan message board
paul the user was nicknamed q after q
level security clearance that's the
energy department equivalent of top
secret
the community that followed and believed
those anonymous postings became known as
q anon
and they developed an elaborate
conspiracy theory lore that president
trump is fighting a global trial
trafficking network
led by satanic cannibalistic left-wing
pedophile elites
their theories have been proven false
time and time again but that didn't stop
the community from spreading
from 4chan to another messaging board
8chan and to places like twitter
youtube and facebook and as it did the
posts
videos and memes explaining its ideology
became more accessible
and digestible now qnon is a giant
entanglement of conspiracy theories with
dozens of offshoots that invites all
different kinds of conspiratorial
thinking
into its fold kyoto has always been a
big tent conspiracy theory that invites
people of different beliefs
and the thing is because the q a
narrative is so broad
and sprawling people can kind of enter
it and pick out the the
things that they like the best that
paired with the facebook algorithm
which uh recommends like other groups
that someone might be interested in
that turns into a very uh dangerous
combination
the q anon follower blocked the hoover
dam with an armored vehicle
a far right conspiracy theorist was
planning a kidnapping and douglas
guy a 24 year old man was charged in the
shooting death of a reputed mob boss
his attorneys argued he was motivated by
q anon
in 2019 the fbi labeled hunon as a
potential domestic terror threat after
some q anon followers started committing
serious crimes in the real world
on facebook q anon related activity grew
steadily for years without consequences
but then something changed there is a
lot of evidence that suggests
that the pandemic had a big effect on
the growth of q anon the
the impact of people spending a lot more
time indoors
and being online a lot more combined
with the stress of the pandemic and the
uncertainty of the future
uh that was a toxic combination that
pushed people into q a
in march three leading q and on facebook
group saw their membership rise from
under fifty thousand to over three
hundred thousand
by august an internal investigation in
facebook reviewed by nbc
found that a number of qnon groups and
pages had more than
3 million followers on august 19th
facebook announced that it would be
banning hundreds of q on pages and
groups
and after that traffic for q and on
phrases and hashtags
fell but membership in groups posing as
anti-child trafficking groups exploded
and in those groups users were still
largely spreading q anon content
q anon followers had simply pivoted to a
new hashtag to improve their image
one that was already being used for a
fundraising campaign by a uk-based
charity save the children i suppose for
someone like me who's kind of been
covering q and on for the past number of
years
like the past six months have kind of
been you know it's kind of been like
watching a tsunami in slow motion
save the children is as i say it's a
simple rebrand of cubanon
it's a very simple and effective message
to bring the q on movement to a wider
audience
you know who doesn't want to save
children
it's hard to accurately trace how the
save the children hashtag jumped from
these cute on facebook groups
to mainstream accounts on instagram but
by july
high profile accounts like model helen
owen and the real housewives of orange
county's kelly dodd
boosted the hashtag with inaccurate or
misleading statistics
this coincided with the united nations
human trafficking awareness day
other accounts put together slideshow
style infographics
like these and these are all packaged up
in very pretty posts
that are you know essentially they're
very easily digestible especially to
people that are not familiar with q and
on
their their colors are so a lot softer
there's a lot of pastels and it's very
pretty and nice and and when if you look
at it without reading the words you
would think it would be
just like just any other kind of uh yoga
inspired um you know instagram post
and so the move to instagram kind of
brought you know it brought cuban on to
this kind of
lifestyle influencer circle really and
many of these influencers already
they already have very high followings
and they already have a dedicated
audience that will
you know very much listen to what they
have to say accounts that might
otherwise be getting just a few hundred
likes on posts
found themselves getting tens of
thousands of likes as soon as they
started posting about save the children
a lot of people who get into q a
especially if they're struggling
influencers
they notice that these q and themes
they're like an internet cheat code
because they attract people who are very
engaged they spend a lot of time online
and if you start promoting keyword on
themes you start noticing that you're
getting a lot more likes and shares
that could be a big incentive to keep
doing it
perhaps the most damaging part of the
save the children movement is how
inaccurate information is making it
harder to fight actual trafficking
one of these most often cited statistics
is that 800 000 children go missing
every year in the u.s
that number comes from a 2002 survey
that asked parents if they had reported
their children as runaways sometime in
the previous year
797 and 500 said that they had
the 2019 fbi data puts that number
closer to 421 000.
roughly half of those reports are
related to custody disputes
and the rest mostly relate to runaways
but even then that number refers to
children who are reported missing by
their parents
the vast majority of whom over 99
percent return home within hours or days
in that 2002 study only 115 were
considered stereotypical kidnappings
there's no reliable data on how many
people are trafficked in the u.s
each year but stereotypical kidnappings
aren't what trafficking usually looks
like
instead it often takes the form of
forced labor or wage theft
most commonly in agriculture domestic
work or sex work
and the people most at risk are those
already vulnerable youth experiencing
homelessness
in foster care or unstable housing lgbtq
plus youth who have been kicked out of
their homes
or migrant young people most people kind
of have this idea in their head that
it's you know children being lifted off
the streets
and been shipped overseas you know and
you know all of that that does happen
it doesn't happen at all to the extent
that you and unfollowers believe that it
does
but the hysteria caused by distorted
numbers has led to a deluge of calls and
outreach from concerned q anon followers
and it's overwhelming the organizations
fighting actual child trafficking
and that's very damaging because it made
it harder for people with real
information about possible human
trafficking victims
to get through and so we've seen this
actually repeatedly the ways in which
the misinformation
that this that this kind of save the
children style of q anon
is uh is promoting damages real efforts
to actually help children
you won't find any searchable hashtags
with typical q and on language on
instagram anymore
but because save the children isn't an
inherently harmful tagline
moderating it has proven particularly
difficult and tackling misinformation on
instagram can be harder than on facebook
since it's harder to train an algorithm
to recognize misleading text in
slideshow images
than it is to recognize text in facebook
posts or comments
the belief in q anon definitely falls
along a spectrum i don't think you can
say that everyone
that was how to say if the children
rally believes that hillary clinton
needs children it's the hysteria
it's the hysteria that grows and grows
and grows as you're going down that
rabbit hole
that could more than likely eventually
lead to you thinking that hillary
clinton needs children
cuon has really struck on something
clever in that
people get confused in their own way and
they fall down their own individual
rabbit holes that
that radicalize them according to their
own personality type
there are more than 20 candidates for
congress who have expressed support for
q anon
the real danger is that people don't
need to believe or even be aware of
the entirety of a conspiracy theory for
it to start influencing
their decisions
you